i've reviewed all the defendant's
evidence as to her counterclaim and i've
considered
the arguments of her counsel and
plaintiff's counsel
first to address a few issues that i
believe are outside the motion to strike
and that's as to the slap defense the
slap defense is just that it's a defense
so it's really not considered an emotion
to strike um having said that we we went
down that legal road on friday as far as
the slap defense goes as far as the jury
instructions in this particular case
if the plaintiff prevails it must be
with actual malice therefore if it's
with actual malice immunity does not
apply under that statute so we will deal
with that with jury instructions and we
have
um as to independent uh contractor
again i think it's outside the motion to
strike however mr waldman was
plaintiff's attorney since 2016 before
the initiation of litigation there is
evidence that mr waldman had a certain
role during the prior divorce
proceedings in the uk case additionally
there is evidence that shows his legal
representation was broader than just a
limited litigation as outlined in all
the cases presenting an attorney as an
independent contractor
so the only evidence in this case to
this point is that mr waldman was an
agent to mr depp and that is the basis
to weigh the motion to strike
as far as the opinions argument again um
i think that is outside the motion to
strike the opinions argument the court
has already ruled on this matter as to
the three statements that are issued in
the counter claim uh ruled uh that they
were not opinion at the demurring at
summary judgment so that argument
will not be part of the motion to strike
so when assessing a motion to strike the
court accepts the favorable evidence
adduced as true towards the non-moving
party the court cannot reject any
inference from the evidence favorable to
the non-moving party unless it would
defy logic and common sense when there
is any doubt in question the court
should overrule a motion to strike
agency may be inferred from the conduct
of the parties and from surrounding
facts and circumstances when there is no
direct evidence circumstances may and
usually are relied upon to determine
whether an agency relationship exists a
principal is liable for the tortious
acts of his agent if the agent was
performing his principles business and
acting within the scope of his agency if
an agent's torturous act arises from
their agency relationship is enacted in
part to service the principal the
principal can be held liable for the
tort here the alleged tort is defamation
besides demonstrating the agency
relationship the defendant must prove mr
waldman published an actionable
statement meaning a statement that is
both false and defamatory with the
requisite intent as to agency mr waldman
was plaintiff's attorney the time of the
alleged uh defamatory statements were
made
mr waldman does not deny this and
neither does the plaintiff moreover mr
waldman made the allegedly defamatory
statements about the defendant during
the proceedings of this action and
interacted with the defendant once the
statements were made while still
representing the plaintiff taking the
surrounding circumstances as a whole an
agency relationship can be inferred and
thus thus the scintilla of evidence
regarding agency must be turned over to
the jury in addition the jury may infer
that mr waldman made these specific
statements to a third party to serve as
plaintiff by betraying defendant as and
oppose an opposing litigant in a
negative light
it is not disputed that mr waldman
published statements and that there is a
question there is a question as to
whether statements are false and both
parties disagree and have presented
conflicting evidence as such as to
actual malice mr waldman made the
counterclaim statements after he met
with his client in addition there is
evidence that plaintiff was with mr
waldman at a meeting in february 2020
with the daily mail online further
defendant claimed that she met with mr
waldman where he threw the paper
containing the counter claim statements
within them uh consequently there is
more than this until of evidence that a
reasonable juror may infer mr waldman
made the counterclaim statements while
realizing they were false or with a
reckless disregard for their truth it is
not my role to measure the veracity or
weight of the evidence the fourth
circuit and the virginia supreme court
have made it crystal clear that actual
malice is a question for the fact-finder
so therefore the plaintiff's motion
strike is denied okay
thank you